we are following breaking news in the
western Pacific a rescue mission is
underway right now after US Navy plane
crashed with 11 people on board the sea
to a transport went down in the ocean
south of Japan eight crew members have
been found so far and are in good
condition Ben Tracy flew on one of these
planes just last week he's with us from
Beijing Ben good morning good morning
this c2 cargo plane crashed while it was
returning to the USS Ronald Reagan on
Wednesday afternoon and this happened
while the US and Japanese forces were
conducting joint naval exercises now the
plane went down just southeast of
Okinawa which is one of the southernmost
parts of Japan Japan's Defense Ministry
says an engine malfunction in the c2
cargo plane seems to be the cause now
last week we were on the USS Ronald
Reagan as it was engaged in a rare
military exercise near the Korean
Peninsula that involved three US
aircraft carriers we flew on and off the
ship in a c2 cargo plane and I can tell
you they do require you to wear a life
preserver around your neck while they're
on that plane that could be why they
were able to find these eight people so
quickly this has been a deadly year for
the u.s. 7th fleet in the Pacific and
two other incidents earlier this year
seventeen members of the Navy lost their
lives very sad story thank you very much
Ben Tracy reporting from Beijing